I want to ask you you start your special
asking are we going to be okay
yeah that's how you start your whole
special which is coming out on HBO tell
us what you meant by that are we gonna
be okay uh really it was because what
have you heard that Donald Trump is the
president of the change and then so
people were like it was kind of
questioning it are you okay yeah I just
did a classic spit - it was really good
beautifully done it was really good I
tried to play it cool I didn't want to
like react no no you did well no I was
like what what Costello do anywho they
don't know who you're talking about
[Laughter]
they don't know they don't know yeah so
Donald Trump won people seemed so not
okay yeah and I was just kind of
checking in on everybody right you know
making sure would be okay it's weird
it's kind of it's weird right
yeah it's a weird time right now it's
been he's been in office now which I'm
out of today ten weeks yeah and every
day is stranger than the one before and
we still use that when we still like
just like function and stuff you know
it's like a it's like how factory
workers for Willy Wonka must have felt
because all of us have to just ignore
the crazy [ __ ] I leaders do it we're
just like just yeah okay yeah a kid just
explode it but we got it you just gotta
make those chocolate man except we would
be balloons yeah yeah
you